This program is being presented to you
by the Heraeus International Winter
School on gravity and light.
Welcome to the sixth lecture whose title
is fields and it means fields in the
sense of physicists and the notion of
field was introduced into physics by
Faraday who didn't know any mathematics
by modern standards and in fact he
invented the fields to deal with that
fact.
Now today we'll in this lecture draw
many pictures that will
pay tribute to the fact that this can be
all understood by pictures like Faraday
did. However, in order to really work
with it we need some mathematics that
underlie the pictures in a one-to-one
manner and that I will introduce. So the
basic idea is that so far we focused
technically on a single tangent space
and a vector in there, a co-vector,
maybe if you chose a chart on the
manifold you a coordinate induced basis
on that chart so this would be
if you carry back the
grid from RD back to here it may look
like this or like a polar coordinates
something like this and that would
induce a basis here at this point and
then you could decompose this vector in
this basis. This was the D by DXI or in
the co-tangent space to DX1 to DXD basis
induced from such a chart choice but
nevertheless we were always technically
at one point.
Now as physicists we're interested in
vector fields for instance so we want
everywhere we want to think about a
vector such that just any point there is
a vector and I just draw a few and the
question is how do you deal with this
technically?
Now of course you can say well just
imagine at every point a vector and
that's how you usually introduce this.
Now imagining is dangerous because you
may imagine something different from me
so we need a proper way of saying what
imagining is and actually the proper way
of doing this is the so-called theory of
bundles.
So we will develop it.
Bundles.
Definition.
A bundle
is a triple.
It consists of three pieces of data.
E
pi
and M
where E is a smooth manifold.
So some people would call this a smooth
bundle but we will only consider such so
we just call it a bundle consists of a
smooth manifold E which goes by the name
total space.
But that's just because I don't want to
say E all the time and sometimes it may
be called E prime. They're always the
total space of the bundle.
This is again a smooth manifold M
called the base space
of the bundle.
And this pi
is a smooth, you guessed it, map that is
surjective.
A smooth map between smooth manifolds
you know what that means. We defined
stuff like this and it's a surjective
smooth map and it goes by the name
projection map
of the bundle.
That's it. That's a bundle. Any three
pieces of data like this are called a
bundle.
Example.
I could take E to be a cylinder
a two-dimensional cylinder.
Let me draw a picture.
So it's continued
arbitrarily. I could choose M to be a
circle
and always equipped with a topology and
a smooth atlas and blah blah blah blah.
So I have M the circle
and you may think of it. I mean as you
know it's a picture. You know every time
I say picture
it's just for your intuition. It's not
mathematics and mathematics is here.
It's a picture. And pi is a map from E
to M. Well I can choose it as long as
it's smooth. I could for instance think
of the surface of this. I put pick a
point on the surface of the cylinder and
I could associate this point
here on the cylinder to this point down
here. So if this is the point
little E in the cylinder, this is the
point pi of E in the base space because
pi is such a map and as long I can
invent any map I wish
as long pi of E prime, if this is the
point E prime, I can invent any map I
wish for any points here. I mean need to
map all the points as long as the map is
smooth and it hits all the points of the
base space.
If I'm not very imaginative
I might
in this
picture
choose
every
all the points that lie on this line
to project to this point.
And all the points that lie on this line
to project to this point, right? And all
the points that lie on the line here in
the back
to project to this point in the back.
But that's just one choice of the map
pi. Any choice of manifold E, any choice
of manifold M, this is just this E is
here the surface, right? And any map pi
that satisfies this is called a bundle.
There are enormously many bundle
bundles.
Okay. Now
that's pretty. Now definition
a fiber. So if E pi M is a bundle
and P is a point of the base space
we define
the fiber
the fiber over P.
The fiber over P is something extremely
simple. It's defined as the pre-image
of the set with the element P with
respect to the bundle map to to the
projection map. The pre-image meaning
for instance here the pre-image of this
point is this entire set.
It's the fiber over the base point but
the fibers are not the primarily given
thing. It's the bundle projection
primarily given. The fibers are a
derived object. That's the fiber over a
point.
Now comes already the basic idea of
field so in a sense Faraday comes in
very quickly
but we'll only talk about vector fields
and so on after some more work and
that's the definition of a section. It's
a key principle.
A section of a bundle
and let me be very intuitive.
The bundle is
this type of data.
We project down. I write it like this. A
section, let's say a section sigma what
is that? It's a map that goes the other
way.
That goes from the base space to the
bundle.
Now there will be an extra condition for
the map to be a section but it's useful
to first not impose the condition. I I
do it in in two minutes but to think
about what this could be. Let's go to
this image here. You could take a base
point, say this one
and you could send it by sigma, if it
was just a map without further
condition, to any point in the total
space. For instance, you could send it
here.
This could be sigma of the base point P.
Agree?
In other words, it could lie in a
different fiber than the fiber over the
base point.
We don't want that.
We require
that if you
first go up with sigma and then you
project down, you land at the same
point.
Projecting down after having gone up
is the identity on the base space.
That's the requirement for a section.
Otherwise it's just a map from M to TM
and you see a section of a bundle
requires all the structure the bundle
has to give. It requires the E and the M
as the target in the domain and it
requires the pi by this compatibility
condition. And
as a physicist imagine we were able to
construct as the fiber over a point, the
fiber would consist of all the tangent
vectors at the point.
What would a section be?
It would go to a point
and pick an element associate to the
point an element of the section of the
fiber.
If it's a section, right? The same
fiber. That means vector in this tangent
if the fiber was the tangent space. I'm
abstractly speaking now, right? Well for
the circle it's actually true because if
you have a circle
and you look at the tangent space here
and the tangent space there, as a set,
this is just a cylinder, because as a
set, you grind it,
you
put these all up and then you have have
it like this. So, this is indeed the
so-called tangent bundle of the circle.
Okay?
I'm I'm just I'm going to make this
precise, but the point is you don't want
a vector field where you say the vector
at this point is a vector over here.
You don't want that. You want a vector
at this point is really in that tangent
space. Well, nothing else is the idea of
a section.
The sections are the fields. What type
of field depends on the fiber.
So, the base space is the manifold.
And when we want a field which is a
vector field, we need vector space
tangent vector space fibers, and then
sections in the big construction
are the fields.
In that case, the vector fields. What
would be a co-vector field?
Well, it would be a section in the
cotangent bundle where you achieve, and
do this explicitly, where you make the
construct the fibers from the cotangent
spaces. What's a tensor field? Well, you
over the ten over the base space, you
construct fibers. Of course, it's higher
dimensional, you can't draw this
anymore, that are tensor spaces.
So, you have a tensor field.
It's very simple what a field is. The
intuition is right. At the point, in the
tangent space, you have an object of
that type.
Okay?
Side remark. In quantum mechanics, in
quantum so, aside,
in quantum mechanics, we talk about
a wave function on the position space.
And we say wave functions are functions.
They're not.
Wave functions are actually
sections
of a C line bundle over the base space.
You have the base space, you attach to
each point a complex line,
and you do a section. You say, "Well,
that's exactly this. To a point, you
associate
a point in the fiber. So, isn't that a
function?"
Not quite, because on such
constructions, on such bundles, over
such bundles, it's a bit more
complicated, but roughly speaking, you
can define covariant derivatives. And in
quantum mechanics, if you want to do
quantum mechanics in curved coordinates,
you run into a wall with thinking the
wave function is a function.
The wave function is a scalar field
on the base space. You say, "But a
function is a scalar field." No, it
isn't.
Fields are always sections, and there
are subtle differences.
On a function, you would act with
something we'll introduce later, a
covariant derivative in a trivial
manner. On a C section, you can act in a
non-trivial manner, and that makes all
the difference.
So, the wave function of quantum
mechanics is also a misnomer. Anyway, so
that was just an an aside.
Uh fields, fields, very important.
Okay.
So, um
Right. So, that was the were the
introductory remarks. I think the ideas
Yes?
Just a question. So, that the psi, which
is the wave function,
are the components, and not
not the So, aren't we mixing up tensors
and tensor
components when we
talk about whether
It's with with the C bundle, it's a
little degenerate. Okay, so the question
is how exactly that works in in the
quantum mechanical context.
I don't want to go into detail now, we
can do this afterwards, okay?
It's true that locally, I can always
represent such a section by a function.
But the whole point is the global
question, and the question what is the
momentum operator? Is the momentum
operator a partial derivative, or is it
a covariant derivative with the
appropriate connection? And if it was a
function, then the
covariant derivative is always equal to
the partial derivative, but this doesn't
transform right if you go to non
if you go to a curved space. For
instance, if you do quantum mechanics on
a sphere.
Okay. Anyway, I don't want to go into
this. I just I mean, please, you can't
understand this, right? It's just my
answer to this question. It is really
just an aside, okay? I just want to say
the field concept even in quantum
mechanics, you have it, too. Okay?
Okay. So, um
Now, let's become
even more precise. I mean, the
definitions are precise, and the
pictures are a lot of talk. Let's be
precise. Second, tangent bundle
of a smooth manifold.
We need this because we want to
understand vector fields, and these are
sections of the tangent bundle.
Uh
So, we need to understand this. The
tangent bundle of a smooth manifold.
We'll do this construction in detail,
because it's fantastic practice of all
the concepts we have. Yes?
No, it's the definition of a section is
a field?
A section is a field, and what type of
field it is depends on the choice of
total space.
Let me do our primary example for
general relativity that we need, and
then maybe the question
is is clear, okay?
So, tangent bundle of a smooth manifold.
So, let M O A be a smooth manifold,
which is going to be the base space of
the bundle we're going to construct,
okay?
Um
First,
as a set,
as a set only, we define TM, that's the
so-called tangent bundle, it's just the
name of the set,
tangent bundle,
we define it as Well, we take the
tangent spaces, which we know,
at each point P,
and we all throw them into a big bag.
And we do so in a disjoint manner. So,
it's the disjoint union of all the
tangent spaces.
Well, why is it disjoint? Well, the idea
is
you have a tangent space here, TPM, you
have a tangent space here, TQM. Well, a
vector in here is quite a different
thing from a vector there.
Okay? So, if you throw them into
a bag, you still know this is a
different thing than this one. Right?
Different object. This is the disjoint
union. This is as a set.
Okay.
Now, that is supposed to be the total
space of the bundle we're constructing.
I don't call it E, I call it TM, because
I constructed it from the M from the M.
Okay. So, now the second piece of data I
would like to have
Yes?
Disjoint given is this a special case of
a union?
It's a union where um you Well, first of
all, this is just um
an emphasis, right? It emphasizes that
the elements There are no elements to be
identified from the dif- from the
different sets, okay? It's like you all
have a nose.
And your noses constitute a vector field
in this room. Okay, well, you need a
point at every point, okay? And if I cut
all your noses off, and I collect it in
a bag,
I can roll it around, I have this set,
but it doesn't mean that your nose is
all of a sudden Kurt's nose, right?
They're still different noses.
Okay?
Good.
Right. So, that's this. Now, the the
second piece of data is you construct
the projection map. We want a map from
TM to M, but now as a pure map, I can't
talk of smooth map yet, because this is
just a set. But first, I need a map.
Now, what is the map? Now, that looks
funny. I take an element X in TM, I take
an element out of the bag of noses,
and I map it to P.
What is P? Where P is the unique
point,
the unique point P in M such that the X
I took from the bag, the nose I took
from the bag, is the nose of Mr. P.
So, I put any element out of the bag,
and I say, "Oh, that's Kurt's nose."
And then pi of Kurt's nose is Kurt.
Okay?
It's unique. It's unique because of the
disjoint union.
If you put in noses, and they are the
same noses, then I wouldn't know whose
nose it is.
So, and obviously, I hit every point,
because I took every tangent space. So,
it's a surjective map.
Surjective.
Great. So, where are we now? So, what's
now the situation
at this point?
The situation is I have a smooth
manifold M by assumption, right?
And I constructed a mere set TM, far
from a smooth manifold,
and I constructed a surjective map,
of which I can't say yet whether it's
smooth or not, because I need a smooth
structure here in order to start talking
about whether the map I already have
is smooth with respect to the respective
smooth structures.
So, what's the next thing I need?
I need to make this into a smooth
manifold because otherwise I don't have
a bundle.
Cuz the bundle requires this to be
smooth and this to be smooth.
So, the next step C
is to make this into a smooth manifold.
What is a smooth manifold? A smooth
manifold is first of all a topological
manifold.
And once I have a topological manifold,
I can rip pages off the atlas
to make it a smooth manifold.
We make it a topological manifold first.
What is a topological manifold? It's a
special type of topological space.
I need to equip the set with a topology
first. Where do I get it from? Well, I
have a topology here.
Do I have a chance of getting this
topology here?
Ah, I could require that the topology
here
is the coarsest topology such that the
pi is continuous.
So, I construct idea or construct
topology
on TM
that is the coarsest
topology such that the map pi which I
already have becomes
just that's relates the coarsest just
continuous.
If it's not continuous, I have no chance
of making it smooth.
Okay? Now, why do I insist on taking the
coarsest topology? Well, of course I
could take here the discrete topology.
Every subset is open. Then trivially
this pi
is continuous.
Well, but then I didn't use the pi at
all, the data that I already have in the
pi. So, it's clever not to choose the
finest topology but the coarsest that
doesn't yet destroy the continuity of
this. This is a
concept known as the initial topology.
Initial topology with respect to pi
where you know the topology on the
target and you provide a map and you
equip this with the coarsest topology
that makes the map continuous. It's the
initial topology and it's beautifully
simple because the topology on TM we
choose is simply and you will see in a
second that it's
the coarsest topology. It's the
preimages
of any open map with respect to pi where
U is an element of the topology on here.
Well, at least you need these guys in
order to be pi to be continuous because
the preimages of open sets must be open
so you must include them.
The question is can you do you have to
include more? The answer is no because
you can show
and we do this in the tutorial. Is that
right?
We show in the tutorial that this is a
that's right. Yes, we show in the
tutorial
that OTM is not only called a topology,
it is a topology. The empty set and all
TM are in it. Finite intersections and
arbitrary unions of open sets are again
in it. Okay? So, you believe me or you
check it in the tutorial. Best is both
and that's this. Okay. Yes. This is
actually a definition of coarsest
topology, right? Yes. Okay. Yes, it is.
So, the initial topology is very easy to
write down. For the final topology,
that's the other way around. You know
the topology on the target and you want
to establish a topology on the domain
such that the map that's the the final
topology. There you need the concept of
topological basis. That's something
different. It's a little bit more
tricky. We're lucky here that I didn't
need to introduce that. Okay. So, you
construct it this way. So, at this point
we equipped this TM with a topology.
Great. Now, the question is is it a
topological manifold? As a topological
space, it could be just not a
topological manifold. And if it's a
topological manifold, can you always
choose charts with continuous no with
smooth transition maps?
In order to check this, we will
construct an atlas. And from the atlas
we'll read off it's a topological
manifold and even a smooth manifold.
Okay. Well, of course we construct the
atlas in such a way that it works but we
only use data we already have. To
construct this, we only use the data we
already had. In order to construct the
atlas, we now use the atlas on the base
space.
Construction
of a C infinity atlas
on TM
from
the C infinity atlas
A
that we have on M.
How could we do this?
Well, we just write it down. ATM.
The atlas is supposed to contain what?
Chart maps, right? But now chart maps of
the tangent bundle.
Think again of the circle and these
lines which are the tangent spaces put
up as a set as a topological space and
so on. And we want to start with a chart
or with charts
of the underlying base manifold.
How do we construct from them a chart on
the bundle?
Well, let me draw the picture here. I
think it's useful.
So, this is M. At each of these points,
well M is here the example S1.
This is the point P. This is the fiber
over P and this is in our construction
already the TPM. And the bundle is the
collection of all the fibers and it's
disjoint, right?
And now what we do have, we have
charts here. So, I can take a piece of
this here open open and I can map this
in this case to an R1 because the
one-dimensional manifold. Okay? And on
here I have I have this chart. Question,
can I make from such data can I make a
chart of this TM? Well, the idea is to
take all the
disjoint union of all the fibers that
lie over the points here. So, you take
this TU. So, only this collection is
called TU.
Right?
And you need a chart map that maps the
points of TU.
Well, colors should be different now.
So, the fibers are green here.
You take a chart map that maps them to
well, in this case it's already a
two-dimensional space, right? So, that
is a chart map and it's called psi but
it's supposed to be constructed from
this X.
So, we make a chart map psi
constructed from this chart map X. Well,
the TU is just a disjoint union of the
tangent spaces to the U. You know what
that is. But the psi X I need to write
down.
Where and I claim if you do this
construction for all the charts in the
base manifold, you get an atlas for the
other manifold. But I need to tell you
what the map psi is. The map psi of X
takes you from TU
to
Well, I just claim it is like this and I
construct it I did this to twice the
dimension of the base manifold. It's not
so surprising. We know each tangent
space has dimension of the manifold. If
I put all the tangent spaces to each of
the points, I have a double S
dimensional manifold
if I have a manifold at all.
Okay? So, I do this chart map. It's not
linear because it's a chart map and I
need to tell you how exactly it works.
So, what do you do?
You take a nose.
Some element in here, this one.
In TU, you take a nose and you map it to
what?
Well,
this is now just something I write down
but I have an idea. My idea is aha,
it has a base point and the base point
has coordinates D many. So, why don't I
first of all take care of the base
point? So, I take the coordinate
of
the base point pi of X. Pi of X is a
point in M.
And I take the first coordinate of that
point.
And I do this up to the Dth. I take the
pi of X.
But after that, I take the Dth
coordinate chart. So, the point is this
here this here are the
UX
coordinates. Coordinates depend on the
chart. Are the UX coordinates of the
base point of the nose.
The quartz coordinates.
That's how many? That's D many.
Hm? Clear.
I already used up half of this. Now,
what else do I have to remember if I
want to know where I am here? First, I
only know this base point.
Now, I have a chart and it's a nose.
It's a
vector. I know that the X
is an element of T
pi of X M. It's a vector in the tangent
space to its own base point. Very clear.
So, it is a vector. A vector has
components with respect to a chosen
basis. Well, I of course choose the
basis
that comes from this chart because I use
the chart anyway. I can use it for that,
too.
So, I use the coordinates I expand X in
XI with respect to the chart X d by d xi
at the point pi of X because that's the
base point, right?
Now, it's un it's not so nice to now say
I expand it like this and then I put the
X1 X2 XD X in here, but that's exactly
what I want to do, but there is a
smarter way to do this because if this
is the case, if this defines these guys
uniquely because this is a basis,
I could tell I could look at dxj
at the point pi of X and apply it to the
abstract vector.
So, that's the abstract object I have
and I can act on it with this. What do I
get? I have dxj
at the point pi of X. I act on this
object XI X. These are just numbers and
that's a vector d by d xi at the point
pi of X.
Now, this is a linear map because an
element of the cotangent space, that
means you can pull these guys out. It's
the XI of X's and then you have the dxj
acting on the d by d xi, but that's the
dual basis, so that's a delta ji, so
this is the jth component
I want. So, I can take the abstract
object and act on it with this guy and I
get the component I want to put in here.
So, that's clever. So, I write dx1
at the base point of the object up to
dxt
at the base point of the object. And
that's it. So, I stored in the chart the
information of the coordinates of the
base point and the information about the
components of the vector
with respect to the chosen chart.
That's it. That is the chart map
I have here.
Now, is it a chart map? Does it do the
thing you want it to do? Um
uh note
what is its inverse? If we think of
chart maps and change of chart, we need
to think of the inverse chart maps and
compose that. But first
the inverse of this chart map uh is a
map from
uh
xi X of
T U
which is a part of R2
dim M
up to T U, right? So, I must be able
from just a mere collection of numbers
alpha 1 to alpha D, beta 1 to beta D
because what else are the elements of R2
DM? I must be able to reconstruct from
those
a vector
in the appropriate tangent space. But
how does it work? Well, I said these are
these numbers are the components of the
vector, that's BI with respect to
the basis d by d xi at the base point,
but the base point is given as the
X inverse of the alphas.
Because these are the coordinates of the
base point, then this is the point P
itself, so this guy is pi of X.
Ah, I reconstruct the vector and it's a
vector at the base point and that is all
the nose is whatever nose I picked from
the bag, it's a particular nose. So, I
fully reconstructed the nose.
So, that's the inverse of the chart map
and now check and that's of course what
we're all after. We need to check I mean
I can write down any kind of map. The
question is
is this atlas smooth? Are the
transitions between the such constructed
maps smooth?
So, we calculate
xi Y after xi X inverse.
What is this? This goes from RD to RD
because it's a chart transition map, so
it eats alpha 1 to alpha D, beta 1 to
beta D
and I need to check whether this map is
smooth. In order to know, I best write
it down. What is the map? Well, I first
apply the xi X inverse, so it's xi Y of
What is xi X inverse of this? Well, this
is what I just wrote down. That's beta I
d by d xi at the point X inverse of
alpha 1 to alpha D.
Aha. So, I now need to say what Y xi
xi Y is. Well, that is this construction
and I now only write the ith element of
this here, not from 1 to D, but 1 in the
middle, the ith one. So, I have a number
of those
and then comes the first one. It's the
XI, it's the ith position, the XI after
the projection map
applied to beta I d by d xi at the point
X inverse alpha 1 to alpha D.
There come more of these with other
eyes.
Then come
those here.
I leave out the first few and then I
take again the the ith, right? Uh so,
it's the d xi, yes? Too many eyes.
Too many eyes, yes, that's right because
um what he refers to is I take the ith
position, but I have here a summation
index I, so I make this a summation
index M. Thank you very much.
Okay. So, I now take the ith position in
the second half, so that's the d xi
of um at the base point pi of X, but the
point is uh
the X is actually this guy. Well, I
quickly calculate this. The base point
is of course X inverse alpha X inverse
of the alpha 1 to alpha D
and this is applied to the abstract
vector that is this guy. It's the beta M
d by d xm
at the base point, which is the X
inverse alpha 1 to alpha D, comma dot
dot dot dot, close bracket. It's just
plugging in. Many indices, but well
okay.
So, now we have this. Now, we evaluate
it. Let me see, I continue here.
Equals. So, what is this guy? Well, it's
simple. Look, this is a vector with this
base point. The projection map just
selects the base point X inverse alpha 1
to alpha D.
Ah, mistake.
Xi Y requires here a Y
and requires
here a Y.
And now I need to be careful where I
made other mistakes. It requires here a
Y and here a Y. The rest remains the
same. It requires here a Y and that's
it. So, sorry. So, because of this Y,
this is an X, but this is a Y. I need a
Y here and you need a Y there. Okay? I'm
sorry. Yes? Uh where do we get the Y
from or something?
Pardon me? Where did you say you got the
Y from? Oh, from the atlas. Uh so, for
another map, so check
check uh
Hang on. Check transition map. You take
another chart
V Y with U intersected V non-empty.
Okay?
And uh then you check the transition map
uh
from the image of the intersection to
the image of the intersection.
Okay? As always. Okay. Good. So,
now it's very simple. Look, you have a
vector with this base point. The pi
selects the base point. It's X inverse
and then you have YI. So, the ith
position
is YI after X inverse
of alpha 1 to alpha D. Oh, that's an old
acquaintance. That's the chart
transition map on the base space. Very
nice. So, this is the first D
components. Now, it continues because
the blackboard has ended. Uh you need to
take the next D and I take the ith here.
So, here I have this vector at this base
point with respect to this XM here,
right? And I apply the DY
I.
Now, the DYI is a linear map, so I can
pull the numbers beta M out. So, there
is beta M, then comes DY, importantly
DYI
uh at the base point, at the point X
inverse
of the alpha 1 to alpha D
and this acts on the d by dxm
at the base point X inverse of alpha 1
to alpha D.
Close bracket. No, not close bracket,
yeah. Close bracket here, comma dot dot
dot, big close bracket. Okay? That was
the ith element. So, that's very simple.
So, this one is already the chart
transition map. Now, what is this guy
here? We need to look at this guy here.
This guy is just the beta M
and we know that the Y of a function and
the coordinate maps are all functions on
a vector is actually the vector acting
on the function. That's what we defined
before as the gradient.
And this is still at the base point.
Right? And then of course, I can let
this jump in here by mere notation.
Okay? That is this and that was it.
And now you see this is
the chart transition map
and this is the transformation behavior
map for the components of a vector under
chart transition.
Now, the question is is this a smooth
map? Yeah, sorry. Good.
Yes. Are you
in this
two-dimensional
vector
vectors and covectors?
No.
This is a vector
on which a gradient acts
and selects
a component which is a number.
I get the components of a vector with
respect
to the chart induced basis
by acting on it with a chart induced
dual basis.
That's what I showed here.
Okay?
Okay. Now, the question is is this map
as a map from RD to RD smooth?
Because if and only if it is, we
constructed a smooth atlas on the total
space. Well, inspect it. You take these
real numbers. It's undergraduate
analysis RD to RD.
Is this smooth? This These are these
components smooth? Well, of course they
are because the chart transition map
down is smooth.
Is this smooth in alpha and in beta? In
beta it certainly is because it's a um
it's linear in beta. That's certainly
smooth.
What about in alpha? Well, that looks a
little ugly. That's down here. How do I
judge whether this is smooth? Well, we
just remember what the symbol means. The
symbol means you take the M from down
here, you take the function from up
here, you do it after X inverse, and you
evaluate it at X of whatever point you
have X inverse of alpha 1 to alpha D.
Ah, so the X goes away. It's at alpha 1
up to alpha D, and it is the derivative
of the chart transition maps, but they
are C infinity, so deriving them once
still keeps them smooth. Hooray,
everything is smooth.
Upshot.
We have TM
pi M
smooth manifold
and the pi
is a smooth map
because you see the pi in the chart
represent representation, it takes these
guys to just those guys. It's a
projection to first the components.
That's smooth. So, indeed the smooth is
also obvious.
Hence, we have a bundle
in our sense
bundle called the tangent bundle.
That's it.
Right.
So, that was a lot of work
in order to make a very intuitive
picture precise. But it doesn't only
work for the circle. We showed it for
just any smooth manifold that over it we
can construct a tangent bundle. And more
than that we understood how to deal how
we already have an atlas for it. So, we
can work in atlas if you want. It's It's
exactly the same. And we produce this
all from the data from below.
Now, you might wonder why on earth I put
so much effort
into seeing that the total space is a
smooth manifold.
Well, the answer is very clear.
Third section is vector fields.
The answer to the question I just posed
is
I can make the following definition.
Definition.
A smooth vector field
I want to look to be able not only at
vector fields which are just sections of
the bundle. I don't need this to be a
manifold in order to have some vector
field where the vectors go like this,
but in order to have a smooth vector
field, a notion of differentiable vector
field, a smooth vector field
is a And now it comes in all the work
has been done in order to be able to
write down the following word.
A smooth vector field
uh X Ah, let's call vector fields Let's
call them shy.
A smooth smooth vector field shy is a
smooth map. And that's in order of to
write down this orange word, we had to
invest so much effort. Is a smooth map
Well, you guess it.
You have the
tangent bundle smooth smooth smooth
and a smooth vector field is a smooth
map
that is a section.
Is a smooth map where pi after shy is
the identity on M. So, it's a smooth
section
of the tangent bundle. But in order to
say that this guy is smooth I need to
have a smooth manifold here and a smooth
manifold there.
Had I not chosen that this is a smooth
manifold, I could not talk of smooth
vector fields.
And now you see in the beginning I said
your intuition is right. A vector field
is association of a vector at each point
of the manifold.
But how do I say that this association
is a smooth association?
How do you say that? You can say, "Well,
it just goes like this, right?" But this
is not technically good. Now, we have
the technical way of saying it's a
smooth vector field.
Okay?
So, this is the smooth vector field on a
cotangent bundle. Uh I draw you a little
picture.
So, let's say we look at T
S1
with the projection down to S1, S1 being
the circle.
So, S1 is this guy. It's the circle.
And you can draw an image of TS1
as this cylinder.
Okay?
And now on the circle I make you a
picture of the circle separately. That's
your world, right? Your circle.
And now you may think, but this is just
thinking. It's not technically. You may
say, "Well, there is a vector field here
that points like this. Here it has
become smaller. There it's zero. Uh here
it has turned around. Uh uh here it's
zero again, and here it's growing again
a little bit, right?"
And how do you represent this as a
section here? Well, you have for every
point, say for this in front, that's
this fiber here. It's the fiber here in
front, right? If I match the pictures.
Uh there it's the zero vector, so I
choose this point out of the bundle.
Now, at this point, that's this point
here, uh that's in vector in
mathematically negative direction, so I
say it's this guy here. That's this
vector. I go further to the back. So,
that's the point here
in a fiber over this point in the back.
Uh there's a vector mathematically
negative.
Uh say it's even bigger. That's this
point and so on. And you you get you get
the idea. Uh the section is just um
is is is just something in here, right?
You you associate all these points, and
that corresponds to this vector field.
Okay?
Okay, so that's the image to it.
And um but now comes a very very very
important point, and it's a point that
makes you understand stuff that
otherwise you wouldn't.
And um
and there's an awe-inspiring headline.
It's called the C infinity
M module
gamma of TM.
Pardon me?
Indeed.
Okay.
I think there's nothing else I want to
say.
No, it's fine. It's fine. So, it's it's
four. You're absolutely right.
Okay.
The C infinity module
gamma of TM. Well, I first of all tell
you what C infinity is you already know.
It's the collection of all smooth
functions. You already know it's a
vector space, right?
But you can always multiply two smooth
functions with each other.
You get a smooth function. So, this guy
is not only a vector space
with an S multiplication with R, but it
also has a fat multiplication that takes
two elements and makes them to an
element.
And this thing is
commutative here, associative. There is
a neutral element. That's the function
that vanishes everywhere.
Of neutral element of addition. There is
an inverse element of addition, minus
the function.
About multiplication, it's commutative.
The pointwise multiplication.
It is associative.
Is there a neutral element for
multiplication? Yes, it's the constant
one function.
Is there an inverse for every function
that's non-zero?
No, because a function that's non-zero
as a function sending everything to zero
may still be zero in some points.
That means this structure satisfies the
Cayley-Cayley
D
plus plus plus plus times times times
times, but this is only for this without
the zero function and the distributive
law, which mathematicians call a field,
like the real numbers.
Right? So, Q is a field and the real
numbers are a field, that isn't a field.
Okay?
But, not this one.
So, it's not a field.
It's a so-called ring.
You say, "Okay."
It's
terribly important because now we do the
following. We look at this gamma TM
first and I'll tell you what the
relevance of this ring is. The gamma TM
is the following. The gamma TM is very
simply
the collection of all sections over TM.
Or you could say
all vector fields.
Smooth
section.
So, if you collect all the sections over
a bundle or here the tensor fields, you
have this set. It's a set.
Now, this set can be equipped with an
addition
where you take two such
vector fields
and you define a vector field, which is
defined such that if it acts at the
point, if it acts on a function,
it's defined as the action of the first
vector field on the function plus the
action of the second vector field on the
function, but the vector field acting on
a function is not a number like a
vector, but it's an element is a
function again and this is added like
this.
Now, you might say, "How do you if you
have a vector field that is a map from
here to here?"
I'm sorry. That is a map from here to
here, how is it supposed to act on a
function? I must put a point here.
Right? And the idea is a vector field P
if I write this shy, I associate to this
an XP, namely the evaluation of the
vector field at a point.
And with that one I can then act on a
function. So, if I write XF, what I mean
is the association of M to real number,
where P is mapped to shy evaluated at P
then acting on F. But, intuitively it's
clear, vectors on a function at a point
gives a number, a vector field on a
function, you can do this at every point
gives you a smooth function. You can add
the two functions, the two smooth
functions, but by that you add you
define the addition of the vector
fields. I'm we're missing here the wave
of the the tilde over the second Yes, we
do. Thank you very much.
You can define this and now comes the
point. You could of course now take a
real number
and make this into an R vector space.
Well, you have an addition, you can make
an S multiplication. You could make
this into an R vector space simply by
taking a constant real number here
and doing this, but you can do more.
You can take a whole function
at each point a different number
and you can multiply this and
this being a multiplication on this CM,
you see this this one,
still gives you a vector field. Of
course, you can take a vector field and
at every point you can scale it
differently.
That's the multiplication of a vector
field with a function.
Now, what we have here therefore is
if I had put here an a real number only,
then I would have said that gamma TM
with this plus and this S
multiplication, I would say is an R
vector space.
Because I have multiplication by R.
R is a number field.
I want it to be
I want to allow to scale the vector
field differently at each point
and so I make it a C infinity M vector
space. It satisfies all the vector space
axioms,
but this underlying
scalars for the S multiplication are
only a ring.
And mathematicians call a vector space
structure, I mean the axioms, over a
ring, they don't call it vector space,
they call it a module.
You say, "Why don't they call it vector
space over a ring?"
It because it is a vector space over a
ring according to the axioms, but it
deserves an extra name because modules
don't have all the properties that
vector spaces have.
If you start multiplying by non-field
elements,
but by ring elements,
you no longer have all the nice theorems
for vector spaces.
So, if we think of vector fields as
being able to add them and to scale them
arbitrarily,
then we deal with a C infinity M module
of all vector fields and I tell you a
conclusion in a second. So, upshot,
vec set
of all smooth
vector fields.
So, this is set gamma TM
uh can be made
as above into
a C infinity M instead of R vector space
no module.
Okay.
Now, this sounds like a mathematical
pedantry,
but in fact,
we have the following fact.
First,
depending on your choice of set theory,
we never talked about the axioms of set
theory. I said, "Okay, we all know what
a set is." Okay, in the beginning.
But, in fact, if you want to prove that
every vector space has a basis,
every vector space
has
a basis,
this requires that you have the axiom of
choice in set theory. So, very deep down
this goes very high up.
Every vector space has a basis.
Second,
no such result
exists
for modules.
So, if you have a module, a vector space
structure over a ring,
where the objects by which you multiply
your objects
S multiply your objects doesn't have
this,
you can no longer prove that there
exists a basis.
That's a shame
because the vector fields,
this set gamma TM doesn't have a basis.
This is a shame
because
otherwise,
we could have chosen
in any case or for any for any manifold.
That's the point. For some manifolds it
works anyway, but for interesting ones
it doesn't work already.
We could have chosen vector fields,
namely dim many shy one
up to shy D
elements in gamma TM
and would be able
to write every vector field
chi, so it's not none of those in the
basis, chi as chi is
the ith basis vector field, a vector
field like this and a vector field like
that on the sphere for instance.
Of course, you want to scale at every
point. Okay, now I'm running here. At
every point you want to scale with some
functions FI
in order to get any vector. So, imagine
you have, say, a unit vector field like
here and a unit I shouldn't say this.
You have a certain vector field here
like this, a certain vector field here
like this, but now you want one that
lies somehow in the middle. Well, you
need to take linear combinations, but at
different points your chosen vector
field could have longer vectors. I
shouldn't say longer,
but anyway, other vectors and but if you
scale at each point with a function,
then you can you could get
the vector field if there was a basis
for this.
So, these would be the component
functions.
And the point is the question is exist
there global vector fields on the whole
manifold
which I can choose once and for all or
another choice and I can expand every
vector field globally on the whole
manifold.
If gamma TM was not a module, but a
vector space with these coefficients or
if these coefficients always had
multiplicative inverses if they're not
the zero function, then this would need
to be possible if I choose the set
theory I chose implicitly all the time.
Now, what is the case, and indeed there
is a very simple counter example to
this.
Simple counter example
which shows that the observation that
this is a module, and hence doesn't have
necessarily a basis, is highly relevant.
The simple counter example is you take
the sphere,
and I want a smooth vector field to be
expressed in a basis of smooth vector
fields. Well, let's try to find a single
smooth vector field on the sphere that
can be element of a basis. Okay?
Let alone two for the sphere. Let's find
one smooth vector field.
Um
Imagine the sphere
had hair.
This is the aging physicist, right? So,
the sphere has hair.
Uh now it has of course hair as this is
sphere, right? It has hair everywhere.
The question is, if it has hair
everywhere, can you comb the sphere?
Um you say yes. Uh
Uh
you can comb the sphere. You can put the
hair
somehow like this. And of course, the
root of the hair is you know, it's
supposed to be the vector field, right?
The hair from the root to the tip.
But you see, if you want this smooth,
well, this is just intuition, but you
can prove this.
Up here you get in a problem. You need
to let the vector field, if it's smooth,
it needs to vanish here and here.
Think Morse theory can tell you that
uh abstractly. You can prove every
smooth vector field on the sphere must
vanish somewhere, but it's still smooth.
Excellent. Smooth vector
Oh,
it should be part of a basis of vector
fields. So, what do you do if you have
another a second smooth vector field
being the second?
One, you can choose of course a second
one that's independent. You can let it
go down here, right? You say, "Oh,
that's great. You can go down here."
But the point is, you do not have Well,
this of course is not possible. You have
to come from behind like this, okay? Uh
it's more like like this, right?
At this point, what if you want to write
a vector field that has a component in
this direction? One of your vector
fields got zero.
So, you may have smooth vector fields on
the sphere,
but you do not have a single one that
doesn't vanish somewhere. But wherever
it vanishes, it loses its power as a
basis for the vector at that point.
You cannot comb a sphere.
This has to do with the set of all
vector fields to be only a C infinity
module, not a vector space, not having a
basis.
So, what do we do? Well, we say we only
always expand a vector field in terms of
components in a basis on a domain where
it's possible. That can be done.
And after all, you don't need to expand
in a basis in the first place.
Because the basis is nothing different
for you could come from a chart and do
this. And if you insist, so for vectors,
you could still say I can always go into
a chart. Right? That's the argument the
discussion one can lead. I can always go
into a chart. Who cares about the the
real world?
As soon as it comes to vector fields,
you no longer necessarily can.
Globally.
Locally still, but not globally. Okay?
So, this is yet another blow to the
idea, let's just do it in charts, right?
Mhm? Okay. So, you see, it's always the
same story I'm trying to convey, and
it's very deep in in mathematical
structure. Uh this is not philosophy.
This is just uh mathematics. Locally,
you can do this, and locally,
however,
so you shouldn't now be too discouraged.
However, d by dxi,
we always put a p here. Now I don't
because now I can con- define a new
symbol without the p down here as a map
from m to tm that's smooth, and that
assigns to a point p in m in a smooth
fashion d by dxi p, that's an object you
again know. And this, if this was a
tangent vector a chart induced tangent
vector at a point, this is a chart
induced tangent vector field. And
indeed, if you have the real world, and
you have a local chart,
then in here, you have of course at
every point a basis, and this is kind of
the
basis vector field from the chart
distributed over here. That's okay, but
that is only because it's local. It's
only on the chart domain.
That's not in contradiction to this. And
in fact, your charts, for instance, fail
at similar points.
Because if you want to write just any
vector field
as a linear combination of this,
that at the point where one of one of
these vanishes, at that point you will
not be able
to reproduce a com- a direct a component
in that direction.
It fails only at a point. It's very
subtle, but it fails.
Yes. So,
I can choose a basis set for a local
area. Yes. Yes.
And
now I need to make sure that I don't
leave the area with these with this
basis set, right?
Yes, but the area could be arbitrary.
So, for example, on the manifold R2. R2
as a smooth manifold,
you don't run into the problem.
So, R2, there are the vector fields on
R2 are still a C infinity module.
However, a C infinity module that
happens to have a basis.
I don't say it cannot have a basis. I
say it's not guaranteed to have a basis.
Then you could say, "Oh, maybe that's
just very remote mathematical
possibility." No, the sphere,
right? Already doesn't work.
So, that's the logical status, right?
And it doesn't prevent us from doing
anything.
It just is another blow to the idea,
just let's go to charts and let's be
done with it. It's not so easy.
Okay?
So, I have 10 minutes left. Um that's
excellent because I can introduce the
final object I want to talk about,
namely tensor fields. Tensor field,
almost everything in general relativity
that you put on the manifold, matter,
but also the geometry itself you put on
a smooth manifold, is given by a tensor
field. So, we really need to understand
what a tensor field is, and you'll see
it's a very simple notion, and it builds
on a C infinity m module that doesn't
need to scare you. You deal with it like
with a vector space. The only thing you
mustn't choose is a basis, a global
basis. Okay?
Six, tensor fields.
So, so far,
we constructed
the sections over the tangent bundle.
In vulgar language, it's the vector
fields.
The set of vector fields.
Okay?
And you can imagine, and you don't want
me to do it in detail, but I want you to
do it in detail in the lec- in the
tutorial, you can construct exactly
along the same lines to cotangent bundle
by mapping a covector to the coordinates
of its base points or an atlas,
and the components of the covector with
respect to the dxi basis,
and you can then make this into a smooth
manifold, and therefore you can consider
sections on it, covector fields, and you
have this. You have the covector fields.
And again, you can scale vector fields
by functions to get a new vector field,
and we had a C infinity m module
defined this way here. And similarly,
the sections of the cotangent bundle
also constitute a C infinity m module.
Forget the gammas. The tpm and the tp
star m were the basic building blocks
from which we understood every tensor.
Well, you won't be surprised that these
two are the basic building blocks from
which we understand every tensor field.
Definition.
A
r n r s tensor
field
t
is a
Leave a little space. Multi-linear
map.
And before, for tensors, we had r
multi-linear.
It's a blah blah blah multi-linear map t
that takes r copies of the sections of
the cotangent bundle,
or in other words, the map
the tensor field will eat
r covector fields,
and it will eat
um
S vector fields
and send them to
the real numbers?
No, to a function.
Because it's point by point. It's a real
number point by point and everything is
supposed to be smooth.
Is a multilinear map
but it's multilinear with respect to of
course addition in this guy but there's
also an S multiplication but the S
objects are now these functions.
So, it's a multilinear map between
modules.
C infinity M is trivially a C infinity M
module as much as R is an R vector
space.
These are C infinity M modules. It's a
multilinear map between C infinity M
modules. So, the only natural
requirement is that it be C infinity M
multilinear. Of course, it could it is
also R multilinear but that doesn't
capture the whole
uh
aspect of it. This is an RS tensor
field.
And in fact, this is an incredibly
practical
uh requirement because in the future
we'll define the Riemann tensor and the
torsion tensor with respect to
additional structure we introduce.
And once you wrote them down, all looks
nice and so on.
But you need to check is the map
multilinear in each
entry and in the scaling part, you have
to check with respect to functions, not
with respect to scaling by real numbers.
Many objects you write down are R
multilinear maps if you feed vector
fields in them but they're not C
infinity M linear.
But only the second type is a tensor
field, qualifies as a tensor field.
Okay?
So, let me give you one example and then
we're done.
And further examples will follow.
And the example I want to give you is
one is an old acquaintance in
field extension.
I define a DF, you remember a for a
function F, a smooth function on the
manifold.
I defined DF at a point.
I define an entirely new object, namely
a DF.
And is a smooth map. No, hang on. Do I
want this? Um
Can do this in several ways. No, I want
it differently. Sorry.
That eats a vector field and maps it
in multilin in linear fashion only one
to a function.
How is this given? I take a vector field
shy.
I plug it in
and I apply the DF without the P point
to the vector field.
Actually, once I write it like this,
already here I know if it really is to
going to be linear, this is going DF is
going to be a zero one tensor
field, right? Because it has exactly
this structure for R equals zero and S
equals one.
I define its action so I need to define
this such that I get a function out. How
do I do this? Well, I define it as the
action of the vector field on F. Sorry.
Now you say, "Hang on, but a vector
field is a map from M to TM. It's a
section.
How can I act on a function? Well,
obviously this is a new type of action
which we always write like this. I could
invent a new
prescription here. One doesn't do that.
Where I but I have to say what I mean by
this. Where shy F
is supposed to be a function so you can
evaluate it at a point in the domain of
the function and it's defined as shy of
P. Now, this is the shy that goes from M
to TM. So, this is the element of TPM
because it's a section so it's at the
point P where it starts from and that
can act on the function. So, this here
is to be read like once you evaluated,
the evaluation point jumps in between.
But this is standard notation to say a
vector field acts on a function and
gives you a function. And that's
intuitively totally clear. But
abstractly, you need to know exactly
what you're talking about because from
where to where does the map go? So, in a
sense here, there is a new application
rule defined, whatever. We we don't uh
invent a symbol for that.
That is this um
that's this thing.
Okay? And indeed, you can check. I don't
do this now but maybe you want to do it
at home. You can check that this DF is C
infinity linear in this entry shy. So,
if I scale the shy by a function G, it's
G times the result. Well, that's pretty
obvious once you go here, you pull it
out, it's G times the result. So,
indeed, it's not only a map from here to
here, it's a linear map and a C infinity
linear map from there to there. So,
indeed, we justified it's a tensor
field. You can make of the gradient at a
point a gradient vector field.
There you see, I said it. A gradient
covector field.
Thank you very much.